just doesn't care about being accurate, doesn't care about any
of this. People have asked him about this. He'll never respond
to it. He has no response. If I knew about a creator, you know,
making death threats, trying to dox people, I'd probably try
to distance myself from that community. Also, the the ultimate
irony of ironies, okay, the ultimate irony of ironies is I happen
to care. Do you remember exactly what Willy's take was when he
knew that Queen and I were getting threatened with like we're
getting dox threats, death threats? Do you remember what his
take was? Do you guys Does anyone remember? These two are so
unlikable. Even when they're being target threatened with their
docks, I can't help but notice how big of losers they are. Lol.
Lol.
I can't recall if there's more to this. From here, I'm going
to probably start going over to the Willy Mac stuff. All right.
Cuz I think it's very interesting that
food traps would raise Willy Mack is like, "Oh, they all say
he's pro Destiny." As if that's like the most insane thing you
could think. Now, is it the most I don't know if it's the most
insane thing you could think. I haven't really claimed it. I've
said he's probably like a useful idiot for Destiny, right? He's
too dumb to understand how he is just plating Destiny's audience.
That's definitely true, but I don't think I've ever said he like
is intentionally trying to help Destiny. That doesn't make any
sense to me with how Nicholas so harshly denounced Destiny, so
harshly separated himself from Destiny, and then Willie Mack
and Nicholas are like close friends. That doesn't that wouldn't
make sense to me, right? That's basically him like in a way starting
to separate from Nick, and I don't think he'll ever do that.
So that's just that's not a part of like my mental model of who
Willie Mack is at all. So I don't think he'd ever do that intentionally.
All right. Okay.
So we'll go back. We'll go take a look at this. Willy Mack has
said that I apparently have attempted to dox him.
So let me go down to this right here. So this is the first post
here. We'll get to we'll get to Desi response to this after.
We'll we'll get to that in just a little bit. Okay. We'll get
to that in just a second. But
uh so I believe this is on a on a fail doc's picture of me that
Destiny himself has retweeted and like a whole bunch of people
basically Destiny says no this is definitely him and like keeps
trying to post this over and over again which is kind of funny
to me that he has any smoke for bad empanada right very very
strange to me. Uh yes, this is also being posted in the Taliban.
Now Willie is saying, "Hey, don't do that." Right? And this isn't
the only time Willy's done this. Willie has posted another time.
It's a It's a fail doc. Okay. Allegedly, that's me, but it's
not. Uh okay. Anyway, so as someone who's doxed, who was doxed
many times recently and has had it spread very rapidly, I think
people should respect Jtox's ask for privacy when it comes to
his face. We've I've I've said this isn't me. We both talked
to each other, but we have left it on the internet. I don't like
seeing it spread. not necessary at I can't even remember what
he said here. The tweets are somewhere. I think I pulled the
tweets out and gave them to somebody, but um they're still up
as well. And then he says, "I actually completely take this back
as I'm currently seeing JTO retweet my docs, my bride's docs,
and the location we are going to be at. LMFAO very based." Okay,
does that sound like something I would do? How long between those
two tweets? This is I mean it's less than an hour, right? If
it was more than an hour, they'd be more than an hour apart.
So, it's less than an hour. That doesn't sound like something
I'd do. So, here's what he's actually referring to. Dickers made
a tweet. Okay.
Dickers made a tweet criticizing Destiny for quote tweeting Gatafumodor
who posted a bad empanada clip where bad empanada on screen pulls
up some pieces of information on Willie Mack. Okay, it's censored
up pretty significantly, right?
It's censored
uh but not enough. Sorry. It's It's censored up pretty significantly,
but it's not enough. Like I I wouldn't like it personally if
if people were quote tweeting that about me. Okay. And Dickers
responded to Destiny, replied and said, "Destiny is against Doxy
now." question mark. And then he got blocked. And that's like
what I'm retweeting, right? I'm retweeting like, "Oh, Dickers
called out Destiny for being like a total hypocrite on doxing."
The two Willy tweets are 24 minutes apart. Okay. So So
anyway, it's that's what I'm retweeting
Dickers was himself quote tweeting a clipper from Queman's community
I think who clipped Queman. Queman didn't look at this video
had it muted and it was playing in the background and some parts
of this Gata Bumador video played on his stream. I don't even
think he was really paying attention to it. He just let it play
in the background. Right. But it was Destiny's quote tweet he
was watching it through. So he's like, "Oh, Destiny's posting
this." Like
I'm just like he the video was playing while he was complaining
about Destiny being a total who can't possibly who can't possibly
criticize bad empanada. Okay, that's like the whole point of
the tweet. I retweeted Dicker's tweet that included that quote
tweet. Okay, so there are some pieces of information about Willie
in this video that I was unaware of. I only listened to Queen
do it, right? I was like on Twitter and I hit play on this and
I went to another tab and was doing something and listening to
the argument he was making, right? So I was broadly unaware.
Not that that makes like a massive difference,
but it seems like Willie is saying now that if you if you were
to quote tweet or retweet somebody who is disavowing doxing in
the neighborhood of dox information about you that that makes
you
responsible for doxing them or for that dox, right? Which is
strange.
So regardless of the tone, so my tone is doxing is bad. I am
I am broadly in a culture of I I think doxing is very bad. I
do not dox people. I do not want people doxed, right? I'm totally
against all of this stuff. And that is the sentiment of the tweet
I'm retweeting, right? And so Willie also against doxing, also
asking people not to dox, right? But by doing so by replying
and and himself, I'm sure he would admit because he probably
thinks I'm amplifying amplifying tweets that
include purported docses of me. So I don't know where he's standing
on a high horse here exactly, right? And I don't know how he's
going to say this, but very funny enough, Destiny puts his foot
in his mouth here. Okay, Destiny complete utter doesn't realize
that all this happened from his tweet that originally had 219,000
views. Okay, it probably had way more than that where he is quote
tweeting this exact video. Quan was looking at the Destiny tweet,
right? So clearly Destiny is far more guilty of doxing Willie
Matt than anybody else, right? Than anyone else. But he's posting
in the Taliban. He regularly reads the Daliban. He engages with
that community totally. By Destiny's rationale, by the way, Willie,
I hope you know, by Destiny's rale, you're open to like so many
things by participating in this culture. Okay. Luckily, luckily
for me, I actually have a lot of sympathy for Willie having information
about him and one of his loved ones posted on the internet. And
so, I understand how he could possibly be uh like hesitant to
or he could possibly get heated and post something that he shouldn't
have, right? I don't think there's any reasonability to the claim
that I doxed him or his fiance. I don't think that's reasonable
at all. Right. I'm literally retweeting something critical of
doxing. All right. Hold on a second. Let me let me take a look
at what else we got here.
Oh, I also was linked to this Gat
clip and I didn't even pull it up on stream. I didn't want to
draw any attention to the fact that any of this stuff happened.
Personally, when I saw it happen, I would not bring up the tweet.
I timed out and some people here can actually like confirm this
because I know I timed people out for bringing it up. I literally
timed people out in my live streams for bringing it up or for
posting the tweet or for even like mentioning it. Right. If you
dox him then Destiny did yet he didn't go with Destiny at all.
Yeah. I would think that his whole problem would be with Destiny.
Right. He's posting the Dow then. Shouldn't he be very very very
upset with Destiny? And I'll say as far as I know,
as far as I know, he hadn't like reached out to anybody. Eventually
Destiny does delete this tweet. Dickers deletes his tweet as
well, right? But it's like I don't think I don't think Dickers
was ever trying to dox somebody. I don't think even the Clipper
was trying to dox somebody. Realistically, nobody even knew that
that stuff was in the video until Willie pointed it out cuz nobody
the video is like happening in the background. Stuff's like minimized
and stuff. It's like not incredibly obvious unless you're looking
at it as the person who is incredibly invested. Right. Anyway,
so I'm on Willy's side here. I think doxing is really bad. I
think you shouldn't dox people. I I was not in support of anybody
doxing that guy. I was not in support of anybody spreading that
or amplifying that. Okay? Obviously, I retweeted dickers just
pointing out the
And by the way, if he by the just so we're clear, if this if
if criticizing doxing or amplifying any tweet criticizing doxing,
if it adjacently includes some doc information, even if it's
like by far not the the main part, although for Willie, he's
criticizing something that it is the main part. So I don't even
know, right?
No, it's not the picture of me as fail docs, but again, purported
docs, whatever.
Right. So, so he is to his mind, like we we just have to step
into his mind. His mind is that is real and don't do that, right?
He's criticizing don't do that. But he's now criticizing me for
amplifying a tweet that happened to include some information
downstream about him and his fiance apparently. Okay,
which is literally the action he is doing by replying to these
tweets. Like to be clear. All right. Now,
I find it just interesting that we go to all of this. Oh, let's
look at the the Destiny response here. Desessie responds, "Just
take solace in the fact that there's a non-zero chance of Cherry
murder suiciding both of them within the next 6 months." Uh Desi,
of course, being a complete He's friends with Cherry. Uh I I'm
in a relationship with Cherry. Obviously love Cherry. Okay. Now,
non-zero chance. The best part about this is I think Cherry would
say, "You know what? I don't know about this part, but the murder
part almost certainly." Okay. There's a very real chance of
That's a very There's a very real chance of that. Okay. Do you
think she's Listen, you've heard her speak about Canada. You
think you think she's going to let herself get buried in Canada?
No shot. No shot. Okay. Anyway,
uh but it's Destiny backing him up. And Destiny, of course, feeling
no shame at the idea that he is in fact, okay, he is in fact
the person amplifying the Willie docks. The thing Willie is complaining
about is something you did a thousand times worse. 100 times
worse. Okay. 100 times worse. Why are you even commenting? Why
is Willie posting in the community in the community in the Twitter
community of the person who spread his docs more than probably
anybody who spread this docs more than Destiny? Is there somebody
who spread this docs more than >> Canada doesn't care about
that. Well, neither of them care about that, right? Willie is
just trying to get a dunk on me for some reason. He like he's
just got a whiff of my ass and he he can't get enough of it.
Okay. I only comment on him being on the internet. He's like
barely regarding Willy's comment anyway. Yeah, he's he's just
trying to, you know, trying to upset people. Hold on. Cherry
did have a good response to this. Okay,
wait. Let me let me pull it up. Go out of here. Where is it?
Here. Where do we have Where do we have What is it? Um Oh, I
should find the community post that goes along with this. Okay.
Char responded to this. Give me a second. Some of you may not
know this, many won't as I briefly reposted about it only 10
or 12 times, but I will be heading to Canada for two weeks to
try therapy or what? You know, we don't even know. This could
be rope therapy, ripe therapy. I'm not totally sure. I've been
wanting to make a series called Get Soon and record my experience
trying different modalities of for anxiety, generalized mood
issues, and pursuing happiness. I designed a self-report measure
with validated measures for depression, anxiety, and psychological
wellness. I am super hopeful you guys enjoy this series. What
I want you to know, what I want to know from you is this. What
questions would you want answered on a video that is per both
personal and empirical on theory? theory is how it sounds. You
get to work on mental health. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. This is This will This will be a self-guided process.
So, what are your questions on the experience? Post them below
and your questions may end up in the final video. This is of
course a reference to a Yeah, I know friends. This is of course
a reference to a not so erodite community post.
Oh, let me try to find this community post here. Where does at
where at? Uh oh. Uh, somebody asked me to Hold on. Can I just
give me a second? There might be a thread of people discussing
this. Okay. Yeah, we'll we'll see this. Okay, we'll see this.
Oh, hold on.
Let's Let's check it out. Clip live. Can anyone prove that JTO
retweeted Willy's docks like Willie claims here? The only evidence
I can find from that date is a repost of a Destiny quote tweeting
Willy's docs. Yeah, Willie is okay with replying in Destiny's
community. Oh, look. De's nuts asking the exact question we should
all be asking. Wait, why is he like posting there at all?
Also, wouldn't your post here be amplifying somebody else's docs?
Shouldn't you like actually understand what's happening before
you do that? Cherry memes way too hard for me. Okay, that's that's
crazy. JTO will be
the
I mean I mean Dr. K. Jesus Christ, dude.
These are spicy. But but
I can't not read them. I can't not read them. I'm sorry. I can't
read funny I can't read funny messages and not read them. I wonder
how many psychological ex psychology experts have hot tub hot
tub khole on their resume. Okay,
let's check this. Let's check out some of the So, this is the
clip live subreddit, guys. There's a couple things here. Yeah,
so I reposted the dicker tweet
and Destiny reposted this tweet. All right. Uh let me know if
I've missed a repost. I even checked the Twitter of Ry Kitten
host Jox editor. I couldn't find the repost where he mentions
here. Never happened. just never happened at all. Okay, never
happened. But
I was going to tweet about this and I was thinking about it.
I was gonna go, look, it's Willie. Once again, another another
episode of Willie not being able to read or engage with any of
the media he sees online. Okay, yet another instance of him not
understanding what's going on, making claims that he can't back
up or or about at all. He's back again to do it again. It's crazy.
Supposedly, Desi deleted the post after Lumpy Willie tweeted
at him. Can't confirm, Lau. Props to Dickers for screenshotting.
I also went to look only on Jtock's Twitter like 20 minutes after
Willie posted his reply saying Jtock reposted it and I didn't
see anything. Well, that would be I didn't even delete the repost.
By the way, the the actual retweet was of Dicker's post. So,
it's this guy knows about Dicker's post and he posts about the
the retweet here, right? He's got the retweet in the thread.
So, I retweeted the Dickers tweet, but when Dickers deleted his
tweet, it disappeared from my timeline. Yeah. Uh, I also went
to look blah blah blah blah blah Chase. Yeah, it's true. I literally
didn't. Uh, wait, was that genuinely Willy's bride? I was 99%
sure it was some random woman and the guy bad up that found.
Okay, so I'm going to keep looking past this. I really don't
want to. Okay, I thought that was a gross and terrible harassment
campaign against Willie and Tommy, though. Why would Willie lie
about this? Why would he, by the way, why would he go to Destiny's
community specifically,
right? Can we think about this? Why would you go to Destiny's
community specifically to make this claim? Can we think about
the the the effects of making that claim in Destiny's community?
It's almost like It's almost like, okay, he's willing to ally
with Destiny against me. And what what would it for me to claim
that he could be pro Destiny in any way? Huh? Personally, if
I knew about a creator, you know, making death threats, trying
to dox people, I'd probably try to distance myself from that
community. You know what I'm saying? Personally, I would just
probably try to distance a little bit. I'd probably try to be
like, "Yeah, I don't really want to engage here a whole lot.
This seems a little up, right?" Especially when you want to then
virtue signal about similar things happening to you. then it
gives you a leg to stand on that you aren't like participating
in that community that and amplifying stuff from that community
where that's happens right this is by this is desgu except desi
has no evidence that I do it is oh he's allowed to dox people
because apparently I support kib farms or something right that's
his argument
I don't believe that but by that rationale if you believe that
rationale supports this stuff right he participates in that culture
would be open but not by mine okay I don't think you can do this
to Willie. I think doing this to Willie is bad, right? Probably
got after trying to stick up for you and out with a Jtock is
bad. He might have gotten, but he he legitimately thought I did
do that. So, it's just it's his poor engagement with the with
the post, right? It's him not understanding what's going on in
the post and getting emotional. I understand the emotionality
part is up, okay?
But I will I will criticize him because it's his job. He's supposed
to post accurate information. He's supposed to be accurate, right?
And he fails to do so repeatedly. He fails to live up to like
a reasonable standard over and over and over again. And that's
the criticism. Okay, I'm not even going to criticize the emotionality
of it.
That's understandable. Okay, let's keep reading. I sympathize
with Willie for being doxed, but he is an has an unhinged hate
against Jto even though Jto is a gaylord. Well, that's not true.
Kind of provably so now, actually. Hey buddy, is is Hey buddy,
is that really criticism? That's a gross haram harassment campaign
moment. To be honest, I get why Willie hates him. That guy went
on asperggo complaining about his Destiny video, especially claiming
No, I didn't. I literally didn't. I literally just said he wasn't
getting the whole story. I I went on a stream two minutes into
the stream. I was just like, "Hey, I I woke up and I was like,
"Hey, I jump on and just point out something, right?" I corrected
his uh his position on Kelly. He totally totally out to me on
that. Totally agreed with what I said about the the Kelly stuff.
And then I wanted to make the point I think about getting the
the cherry storyline and the pattern of behavior correct right
in the video. And I didn't I didn't specify that well. But I
don't think that that wasn't me like complaining about it for
months or something. Didn't do that. Uh basically what's happening
to me is something it's something similar to what happens to
one of the creators around Hassan where like you know even though
he has no participation Shawn Black's blamed for CPS, Shondaanda
Black's blamed for uh what else? CPS and skulls and all of this,
right? We have bad things that happen to somebody and I'm going
to say there's a creator who's sort of adjacent to that. I'm
going to blame them for all of it. Anyway, I agree. JTO did look
like a complete in that situation. Again, Willie agreed to the
the correction on the the Kelly stuff. Like basically, shouldn't
you have asked Destiny? The question was, shouldn't you have
asked Destiny for some evidence of the thing he was claiming?
He's claiming something fairly negative about other people that
they're posting revenge porn of him, right? Shouldn't you ask
him for evidence of that? Yeah, obviously you should. runs from
uh but Willie just lies about and about that and runs from people
like Jtock and Queen and reflects poorly on him especially because
Willie seems to somewhat still be somewhat still favorable towards
Deafne which is
Willie took down the tweet so I think he probably got it wrong.
JTO is still a spur regardless. Yeah, Willie did not take down
the tweet. Willie still has the tweet up by the way just so we're
clear. I think it's very embarrassing for him to do that. I think
he's like being a total weirdo. I think there's probably eight
creators that he should be going at before me, but he thinks
he thinks he could just farm, I guess, that community for likes
and follows about me. This is probably what he's done for almost
all of his uh he's it's probably what he's done for almost all
of his content, right? Is he just tries to find somebody to farm,
but usually he's drafting behind Nicholas or usually he's drafting
behind other creators who are intelligent enough to evaluate
media on their own. Um, this one he seems to be going off on
his own and it's having predictable results. unlucky.
now here's the thing. People will say, "Oh, well, the the Destiny
thing doesn't make sense. He's not somewhat favorable towards
Destiny." Um, this isn't the first time Willy's let his madness
at me get in the way of any critical thinking or reading skills,
right? Or made a totally totally insane critique of me that it
doesn't map onto reality at all. Right? So,
so what happened here? Destiny posted this. And to think this
was the same guy
who spent the last year saying having sex with mentally ill people
equals crazy, huh? Everything Destiny is saying here is true.
Lol. Everything Destiny uh I've never said that. That would be
an insane thing to say. I literally have people with mental illness
in my life who I care about
and I always have. By the way, this is like this is a totally
How would I have relationships with those people and think they're
incapable of having a romantic relationship? It's bizarre. It's
unhinged. is insane. I don't know why I would ever why you would
say I said that. Okay. Well, I know why Destiny just lies about
people, right? That's why deathy would just lie. And Willie doesn't
care to be accurate or correct. Care enough to have with uh at
least one of them. Yeah. Only mute. Anyway, so just doesn't care
about being accurate. Doesn't care about any of this. People
have asked him about this. He'll never respond to it. He has
no response. You other mentally ill people? Dude, listen to me
talk. Yes. It depends on what you mean. Like I just don't think
mental illness is not a thing that you can just put on somebody
and say like, "Oh, it's wrong to have with them." That would
be insane, right? That would be totally insane to make that claim.
At least I was just joking because obviously I was referring
to family members as well. So I was just it was just a meme.
Don't worry about it. Yeah. So I just But I wouldn't I wouldn't
denigrate those people in their agency, the people I do care
about by saying you can't have with them or have any romantic
relationship with them. Yeah. Anyway, but Willie Mack totally
amplifies this. Doesn't care. doesn't care about being accurate
when it comes to me. He'll just totally lie about me and nobody
will call him out on it. Sorry, not nobody. Nobody around the
Destiny community or anybody there. Nobody there cares about
truth at all. Queman orbiters, Chud and and J getting targeted.
Um,
no. Everybody gets targeted, right? Willy Mack is not mad at
Queman. Willy Mack is not doing the thing where he's mad at Queman
and coming after me. He's mad at me. He's been mad at me. He's
obviously been angry at me. Okay.
Also, the the ultimate irony of ironies, okay, the ultimate irony
of ironies is I happen to care, but do we remember
do we remember exactly what Willy's take was when he knew that
Queen and I were getting threatened with like do we're getting
doc threats, death threats? Do you remember what his take was?
Do you guys Does anyone remember?
Does anyone
These two are so unlikable. Even when they're being target threatened
with their docks, I can't help but notice how big of losers they
are. Lolol
which he is lucky I understand Willie doesn't deal with people
like me but I actually just have a principle here and I still
even though he said this am not going to say like oh is open
nothing like that right I still think it's really bad to dox
people I still don't want to participate in that culture whatsoever
it's crazy right and it does suck for for Willie Mack and uh
especially his his fianceé, right? His fiance's had stuff published.
Like it's it's it's super
like that. I have every amount of empathy for that, but I didn't
participate in it like at all. This guy is dumb. He is very dumb.
Okay. He is very dumb.
He is very dumb.
It's but it's like it's just funny and like almost borderline
embarrassing how wrong he can get things and nobody goes, "Oh,
that guy's a complete."
He's obviously a complete
and people don't see it. I don't understand how they never see
it. Wasn't it that other website? Well, I didn't dox him. Yeah,
obviously not.
No, I think it's up. Anyway, trying to think if I've got more
here on the Willyax stuff. I got more on the Willyax stuff. Oh
boy. Um, I've got a lot of issues with his first video, but I
I think I'm going to wait on that to pull some of those things
out. Anyway, Will's like a to complete, right? I just don't understand
JTOK. Nothing against Cherry, but you were really willing to
risk your reputation to be with her, someone you know is unstable.
There are so many other women out there. It just doesn't make
sense to me. Well, Jack Stack, I want you to imagine. Oh, somebody
just banned that guy, I think. Wait, what happened to that guy's
message? That guy's message just disappeared for me. Oh, I see.
Yeah, that guy got banned. Okay. Um, I don't You don't have to
ban that. That's like a reasonable question. I
Yes. Just Yes. Yes. I knew exactly what the outcomes would be.
And yes. And by the way, that's because it's somebody I hung
out with for hours every single day for months and months and
months and months. I don't I have no Is that a reasonable question?
I mean, it's not a reasonable question to ask again, right? Yes.
I I understand that people would um
I understand how people interpret
that. Like I I get it, but I think they're just wrong. I think
I care about this person like super deeply. And yeah, if that
if you if you feel like you can't trust me because of my personal
life, my decisions in my personal life made between like two
consenting adults. I care about this person. If you feel like
you can't trust me given that, that's fine. Off,
right?
Just walk. Uh I I've said this to this is like one of the only
times I'll get um even remotely personal again. Okay? I don't
like getting personal on stream, but something that's all the
thing that blocks me in relationships is never the fact that
um it's never like any of the big things like it is for other
people. It's never like attraction. It's never anything to do
with like or romance or anything. It's that in small moments
dayto-day, I kind of can't stand some other people. Like I I
just have a hard time like getting along with people most of
the time, right? And I don't have that problem with Cherry at
all. Like it's just always fun to hang out with them. That's
what it is. Okay, sorry. That is just what it is. Now, I understand
that people have concerns about how that might overlap with my
content and I I understand that that could be concerning. I'm
working through that. Yeah, I'm working through that. Okay. So,
like 99 90% of long-term relationships, I guess. So, but like
yeah, that's just that is what it is. That's always going to
be what it is. I'm sorry that uh I'm sorry if people thought
I was like enough of an incel to to never do that. Uh Spruce
Willis, I don't think so. Don't believe so. You way overjustify
yourself. I'm not overjustifying. I'm just telling you how I
feel.
That's just how I feel. Okay. It's changed your whole content.
Wait, what? No, it hasn't. I I think that's crazy. I don't know
where my content's changed. The content's like the exact same.
Yeah, I I don't know where the content changed. Anyway, Kev likes
Oh, Kev is a huge NSE s, isn't he? Oh, right. Yeah, I think Kev
is like a huge This is gonna be hard for him to accept
your intelligence for the way Kev name a criticism you have of
any of my takes. Just go ahead.
I'd be happy. You want to lay out you want to lay out a take
I've had. Okay, I'm willing to defend, but you're just you're
like you don't like the vibe because we criticize not soite.
That's like a totally different thing, isn't it?
I think you're the one who changed, Kev. Okay,
you formed a parasocial relationship. You're very uncomfortable.
You're in criticism. That's okay.
You're going to make it. My criticism is that you mute yourself
unintentionally. That's true, Germaanium, and I cannot beat those
allegations. All right. You talk about the Ria Chris stuff. I
haven't gone 15 minutes without someone bringing it up. No, I'm
good. Defending NY is fine. If you want to actually defend her,
but I don't think that's what ever happens, right? What happens
is somebody goes, "You're insane. You're obsessed with this person.
You're totally obsessed with this person." Okay, that sounds
like you're claiming I have bias against them. should be that
I have a bunch of takes against them that are totally incorrect.
Why don't you grab one of those takes and say, "Hey,
hey, can we talk about this?"
How easy is that? That should be so easy, right? I I that's all
I want to hear, right? Instead of instead of, "Oh, you're so
obsessed with this person." I want to hear when you said this,
this was really unhinged and I disagree with it. I watch this
is by the way, mock Rabbit perfectly encapsulates nearly everybody
who who is involved in this conversation right now. I defended
Noto Erdite until I watched any of her content. Then all the
hate made sense. That's basically it in a nutshell. By the way,
some of the debate content like Noto Erdite, I've always said
this and I will always say this, okay? She's like a fantastic
like loud lal for blood sports debates. She is. That's just that's
just facts, okay?
It's very funny. It's very good content. If she's screaming at
somebody in a debate, there's a 50-50 chance she's completely
wrong and doesn't know it. And that's awesome. We love to see
that. 50/50 might be high. I'm not totally sure, but there's
there's a decent chance she's actually completely wrong and screaming
at somebody over a thing that she's unaware she's wrong on. You
you get that very very very uh rarely from people. Okay. Oh,
yeah. Somebody somebody basically asked Willie Mac Show and some
other people. Oh, he replied and said, "So, you're going to go
at I'm not going to pull it up cuz uh Oh, hold on. Let me see
real quick. Let me see this. I'm I'm going to look at this lumpy
Willie tweet. Give me a second. Give me a
Make sure there's no doc stuff there.
There is not. Okay. Yeah, it's just me reposting the dickers
tweet. And like I don't know why you would be mad at me for that
and not messaging other people. Like why wouldn't you message
the person who posted that?
Or maybe he did eventually
before going at me, I guess. Okay.
Am I am I all done with the Willy Mac stuff? I think I've shown
quite a few of the things. Oh, and Willie Mack, just to say again,
I understand he's like he's basically gone to the Destiny community
and made multiple posts there under like them attempting to dox
me or them showing ported docs pictures of me and said, "Hey,
you guys shouldn't do that, right?"
But again, if you're critical of doxing, but amplifying those
those docses, there's like a philosophy there where you just
don't acknowledge, you don't ever talk about it at all. And there's
a philosophy where like you you decry it. But I don't understand
how you can like mix those two. Either decrying it is okay or
it's not. All right, I think that's it. That's it for the Willyax
stuff. What do we go on to next? Was there more Hutch stuff?
I'm not sure if there's more Hutch stuff. I've got one of two
options here.
Oh, wait, wait, wait. There's a there's a Destiny comment as
well. Hold on. Apparently, I got told I should watch this Destiny
stuff. So, before we go into some longer form content, I will
possibly go to Nuck Boys. No, I'm not doing I'm probably not
doing the Iron Mouse stuff. I don't have any of that stuff available.
Second, if you wanted to go collect links for that, I would absolutely
do that story. I'm just probably not doing it today.
But there's Nel Boys interviewing Benjamin Netanyahu and then
they talked to Nick Fentes and then they talked to like they
talked to Nick Fentes and then Hassan and then Sneo and then
Hassan again. All right. And I've heard that basically the entire
time this was going on, Destiny was watching and messaging them
to try to get on the stream and they were going to bring him
on the stream and then Oh, and Myin. Yeah, and Myin. And then
and then they went and uh they just didn't invite him on. They
brought Hassan on again with Adam Freriedeland at the end instead
of inviting him. He's like waiting there to get on. He messaged
them waiting waiting waiting and then they talked to Hassan and
Adam Freeland. They go, "Oh guys, we're out. Bye-bye.
Bye-bye."
So
I think there's probably a lot of content to mind there. Okay.
There is a lot of content to mine there. I think it's it's also
like sort of a who's who of former Destiny friends as well. They
were asking Hassan about having banned people on. That's definitely
why. Oh,
good times.
Good times. Oh, Kev Kev99. We all saw that content already at
Destiny stream. Everybody here was there.
Okay. I'm just so happy that people are psyched to watch it again.
We to watch this guy get Imagine. I wish I was you, Kev. Two
opportunities to watch this guy be humiliated. I wish I was you
right now. Okay. I wish I already had that memory there and then
we were loading it up again to watch it happen again. God, it
sucks that I'm actually just watching it for the first time.
I don't watch Destiny. I know a lot of people here don't watch
Destiny. I just thought I I wanted to read his in the soy voice
and laugh at him. That's all. That's it. That's all. Okay. Somebody
provided this time stamp in the Discord. Let's Let's check this
out real quick. Some of you may know that um many won't as I
briefly posted about it only 10 or 12 times, but I'll be heading
to Canada for two weeks to try therapy. >> The mind of
the battled attempts to understand humor attempts to comprehend
humor. Let's see how this goes.
you think that this is her? Um so I don't know what this is or
I'm sorry. I don't know why, but Cherry is obsessed with um Cherry
is obsessed.
Again, just go to any of the actual factual criticisms and point
out the ones that are wrong, right?
You'd think it's so you would think it's just so embarrassing
for somebody who had this youth to dismiss his criticisms for
years by Hassan and he'd always point out how it was, right?
For him to just go and throw this at other people, put no work
in himself, no effort in himself, right? Because he'd have to,
by the way, what he'd have to do in that case is defend his very
close friend apparently who he thinks is very intelligent.
Does that sound difficult?
How how hard would it be to to defend your friend who is very
intelligent, right? Very intelligent, very good at debate, very
smart from somebody who's obsessed and unhinged and crazy.
Shouldn't that be really easy? I feel like it should be really
easy, but I just never see anybody do it with Kyla. I don't know
why. Um, this thing here, apparently Kyla is trying like ketamine
therapy or whatever. Obsessed, but Destiny is reviewing a 17
like tweet. I'm just glad that Desi is driving follows and stuff
to the cat post irony account. Okay,
get it? Because it's like a cat post, but also post irony. Cat
post irony. You guys get it? These tweets are her um making fun
of Kyla's ketamine therapy stuff or whatever. That's what she's
doing here. >> that's what this is.
>> Yes,
that is what it is. Your JTO, you're going to end up in a tweet
one in a cherry tweet one day. You're gooning to your own cancellation.
Uh, listen, I understand and like every single part of Jerry,
okay? It's just not a problem for me. I'm perfectly well aware
that like there have been tweaks made about me publicly. I don't
care. I don't care. >> Was that public knowledge? Yeah,
there was some YouTube comment I think that she posted a while
ago. >> Oh, nice. Somebody pulled it up for us. >> Oh,
is he going to read it? >> yeah. Yeah. Some of you may
know may not know this or some of you may know this. Many won't.
As I briefly mentioned on stream only once or twice, but I'll
be heading to Boston for two weeks to try ketamine therapy.
Cherry obsessively stalks like every single part of Kyla's life
that she can online and talks about her like incessantly. It's
probably one of the reasons why just
>> Cherry Cherry just watches content and then tweets clips
and other clips there. >> Is also focused on it cuz Justin
has to do whatever he can to keep his um new BPD queen from keeping
herself.
>> Oh, Cherry's manipulating me. I thought I was manipulating
Cherry by being Dr. K. It's really hard to keep track. things
get get criss-crossed and then I'm like very apparently
we're we're stuck in a cycle. Okay. A symbiosis.
All right.
What is the uh hold on?
Yeah. A orus. Okay. I was trying to think of the snake like a
oraoris.
Right. Both people are at the same time. I I don't Some people
Some people might call that a relationship. Okay. These people
are both invested in each other in a way. Yeah, some people might
call that a relationship. Other people call that mutual, I guess.
I'm not totally sure. I don't think we're done yet. Okay. >> Miami
made to kneel to eat. >> I think there's some more stuff
here. >> Is ketamine therapy crazy or something? Doesn't
it have legitimate use?
>> Did I really just do that? Whoops. Whoops.
Some of you may know this, but um many won't as I briefly posted
about it only 10 or 12. There we go.
>> Constantly.
Oh, somebody asked about the ketamine therapy, right? >> Is
ketamine therapy crazy to do or something? Doesn't it have legit
uses? Um, yeah. I mean, there's trials. >> You do that
a lot? I do that a lot. Yeah. I've got a I've got a trackpad.
It's slightly sensitive sometimes. >> Know where the trials
are at right now? It's obsessed. That's lame.
>> Why do you use obsessed? That's lame.
Oh, somebody's pointing out, "Hey, didn't you teach me that it's
like really lame when you just dismiss criticism as obsession?
Isn't that like lame to do?" I could have sworn
Excuse me. Excuse me, Dad. Excuse me, Dad. Uh, I thought you
said like dismissing people's criticism by saying they're obsessed
was like really gross and gay and probably made a joke about
how only people who suck come do it. I don't know why you do
that all the time, but you I think you usually make jokes about
people who just like drink [__] It's kind of weird.
But anyway, I thought you said that it was weird to and and like
[__] drinkers only do that that they say somebody's
obsessed. Okay. I'm pretty sure like the whole account is Cherry
constantly posting about every single thing that Kyla >> says
or does. >> Is it
>> I feel like there are definitely a lot of other things.
>> But also, just to be clear, even if that's all it was,
that should make it super easy. If she posts all the time about
all the things Kyle is doing wrong, that should make it super
easy to grab a couple tweets and go, "This is a crazy This is
like a crazy take. I would This is something insane."
No. >> Or whatever. But like that's that's
>> Yeah. Nobody ever says this exostasis.
Why can't Kyla just stop saying stupid
>> Could we It'd be a lot easier for everybody to move
on if she could just stop saying really
and entertaining things. Okay. That we get to laugh at her. I'm
sorry. There's a reason that there's an entire industry just
laughing at this person, right? You go on YouTube, you just laugh
at this person. It's like plus 200 viewers.
>> Um old Twitter account. Nice block. Techone update.
Kyla. >> So, Teone and Kyla. >> Yeah. Content from
today.
>> Hutch calls into food shop stream and adds the submitted
P OCD to team liberal. Queenman can't even get a call. Oh, Cherry's
also
backing just >> so here's not a not a K post at all >> thing
here because I think um >> wait, hold on. Wait, what? >> Traps
stream adds the submitted P team liberal queen can't even get
a call. Oh, Cherry's also backing Justicle's thing here because
I think
Dang, that's a lot of Kila tweets. She is so jealous.
Okay, Kev, you need some time out. Okay, or if you want, you
can go to the Discord and make an actual argument against one
of the posts. Okay, good luck. You can have some time off. Oh
god. Oh no. Oh no. Hold on a second. Hold on a second. I'm going
to go ahead and say it. Okay. I believe that Kev99 GH guy may
possibly be one of the first candidates for the Incel ranch.
All right. I think I think there's a lot of evidence that that
could be he's hoping to get in line. He's hoping to make it.
He he is a 30-year-old teenager who needs his to be fixed. Okay.
His insult to be fixed. All right. I think um
Queman wanted to talk to Hutch or whatever and I guess Hutch
decided not to do it and
>> Hutch was like literally told, "Oh, this guy's like
a total like loser who will never give you a good faith conversation."
Hutch was told by somebody else, Hutch didn't make that decision
on his own, right? He got information from somebody somewhat
close to him. >> And because Cherry um is being used and
mind by Justic, she's also on team
orus. Okay. Yes. First, Cherry was convincing me to do all these
things and then now I'm convincing Cherry to do all of these
things. It's the Oraoris. Okay. Over and over and over again.
>> Oh no, we've got a surp
what the wrong criticism is. He can't get a clip and say here's
what you up.
Doesn't do it. Doesn't happen.
But okay, the extra ad of or whatever sounds like Lil Stevie
is still playing dumb. wanted to talk to Hutch or whatever and
I guess Hutch decided not to do it and and because Cherry um
is being used and mind by just also on team like oh no we got
because these guys are all like >> circle and trying to
help each other
circle and trying to help each other constantly.
Oh, wait, wait, wait. I understand. Hold on. I understand what's
going on here.
Destiny doesn't understand.
There's like a very, very crazy concept that went on between
Cherry, me, and Quimman that Destiny has never been a part of
and can't fathom, and that is the concept of friendship. He doesn't
understand friendship. He doesn't understand people being friends,
like hanging out, you know, after a stream in a public Discord
or something. He cannot fathom it. He cannot ponder it. It makes
no sense to him, right? He said there's nothing there. There's
nothing there. Oh, by the way, this is another non Kyler tweet.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, hold on.
>> Hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait. >> So, this happened.
So, okay. Wait, wait, wait. I need to go and see all the tweets.
We're going to scroll through >> several trying to help
each other. >> Oh, so not a not an Aerodite tweet. This
is an Aerodite tweet. Unfortunately, we covered some Aerodite
content back to back. So, >> not so Aerodite. Oh, not so
aerodite. >> Not aerodite. Not erodite.
>> Destiny gaslights. And so >> wasite.
Now I will say there was a lot of Ky there's a lot of statements
to point out. Okay. It was good content. This debate was really
good content. The whole thing was >> not so erodite. Not
so aerodyite.
>> Not not so arroite. Not not so arroite.
This one's not so arroite. >> Uh retweet of arise. Oh,
not so >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Destiny,
why don't you play some of these clips? Hold on, hold on, hold
on.
Cuz here's the thing. I've said this already. Even if this was
all Aerodite clips, only Aerodite clips. Why don't you play one
of the clips and explain the problem with it? Right? Where does
she lie? Where does she say something incorrect? You're just
going to go and you're going to do the obsessed meme, obsessed
BPD queen, obsessed BPD mind. Right? It's just a
It's a Marov chain of unhinged woman terms instead of actually
looking at one. Destiny, go watch that clip where she goes, "Do
you know who Destiny is?" Well, Destiny says that Kyla is really
good at debate and like does a really good job. Would that change
your mind on Kyla? Why don't you go watch that clip and then
I get to watch you your soul die. Okay. And then tell me you
want to restart the Bridges podcast. All right. Please do it.
Oh, not so erodite. Oh, not so arerodite. Oh, not so Yeah, she
was obsessed. Like, he didn't watch any of the clips. He didn't
watch any of the clips. He didn't make a comment on any of the
comments she made, right? Zero commentary. Zero clips watched.
Just, oh, it's a Kyla clip. It's Kyla clip. It's a Kyler clip.
So, I guess probably in the same vein, right? In the same vein,
if we go to any clip creator who focuses on a sub community or
on a other creator explicitly, can we just not trust those clips?
Well, shouldn't it be really easy to just go through those clips
and say, "Oh, that's not relevant. That's not relevant." But
he can't hide his hatred for her either. Notice he doesn't call
her by her actual name. Too close. Couldn't wait to close that
last clip. What was the last one? >> Oh, not Sarite.
>> Hold on. What was it?
Let Let not Serite say, "Stop checking people for the past. >> Just
watch any of the clips, bro. Go watch the clips and explain to
me why that's not funny." Yes. to be. So, here's the thing,
and I I benefit from this sometimes, too, okay? Not as much as
Ardite does. Everybody who defends Arerodite tends to be people
who don't watch Arodite content. And Cherry's just making it
so they can see like the moments why everybody else rejects it.
Why the people who have tried watching it reject it? She's literally
helping. She's helping everybody.
Credit Cherry. Hold on. Yeah. You know what? We actually should
watch some of them right now. >> You're kind of based.
We're trying to recruit you. >> Based in what? I haven't
said anything.
You said, >> did you imagine? I just want I want to challenge
Destiny to watch this on stream. Watch this clip on stream. >> Steven
was intelligent. That is Loki
>> You said that Steven was intelligent. That is Loki based.
>> He is. You don't you don't debate and not have like
a high level of intelligence or like an understanding of how
those types of conversations work.
>> What if I told you >> his job literally requires
his intelligence? I wouldn't deny that. What if I told you that
Steven regularly has said that Kyla or not so arerodite is really
good at debate and does a really good job.
>> How would you feel about that? >> Is he God? I
I don't Is he God? I don't
>> do you think I like Do you think I value his opinion
on who is good and who's bad at debate? >> Well, it seems
like you value his opinion on a number of things. So, it would
be weird that you would
>> I thought you said he was smart. Uh, is he not the strongest
man in the room to you? Do you not listen to him over your husband?
Am I am I on an island here where I think Destiny's word is like
law and and like I I just think he's really smart and really
good. Destiny's like really deeply good, you guys. Okay. And
I know I said that his path to redemption meant like, you know,
writing wrongs and admitting fault and being a better person.
And he's done none of those things, but I think he's redeemed
and I think we should all go on tour with him. Okay, let's go.
Okay. All right. Where was I? Oh, I wasn't done yet. Unless he's
done. Is he done?
>> I think he just says obsessed over and over again, right?
>> Oh, not. Yeah, she's obsessed. Like she has been for
years,
>> she has been for years. I think I think Cherry feels
like Who is it? Okay. Oh, man. Cherry's got to feel like like
a journalist covering Prince Andrew or a journalist covering
the the Catholic Church where like a massive scandal is happening.
Millions of people are being brainwashed into thinking this person
has something valuable to say. And Cher's the person who like
sees it and she's like, "Dude, do you guys not see how stupid
this person is? Does nobody see it? Does nobody see it? Hello.
Hello. Hello." She's like, she's found a conspiracy. And by the
way, lots of people do see it. It was just I'm Walter inside
the car screaming. Lots of people do see it now. And I'll just
say,
uh, Queen makes a bunch of, like Queen gets a bunch of views
doing that content. I get a bunch of views doing that content.
There's a bunch of people who see it who see like the the contradictions
and like the over the performiveness that like makes us all cringe.
We all see it now,
but Sherry was the first one who pointed out. I knew the whistleblower
clip was bad. I told I remember telling Aaron I literally told
Straight, "Hey, why don't you point that out how that is?" Right?
I I said to Aaron, "Why don't you point out how that is?" And
then Aaron pointed it out, but I didn't like, "Oh, man." Then
I let Kyla come on my on my stream and say, "No, actually, I
looked that up and I was right." I was like, "We should just
move on because I don't want to engage with that comment, guys.
We should just
We should just move on." Okay, we should just all move on. We
should just Let's not talk about your whistleblower comment anymore.
Okay, that's not a good one. We don't like that.
Uh, okay. Oh, why is this Kev99 GH guy in here? This guy was
unhinged.
You don't know the context of what happened with Destiny. You're
surrounded by mentally ill peoples. Clemen need to get sued by
Destiny. Cleman is a Jtock orbiter trying to bang Cherry next
in neither here and there or their Minecraft. She's more likable
than your dumbass. Go read a book. Oh, this is like Kyla. Destiny's
going to win this guy. How did this guy survive so long saying
like this? He was here for a long time. The whistleblower stuff.
Destiny said NC is a good debater.
Not soite. If she is correct, she she if she is correct, she
optically is like a decent blood sports debater, right? She will
she'll like hammer somebody on a point and it's very good. But
the problem is there's like not a connection between how correct
she is and that level of confidence. So sometimes there have
been times where she will absolutely like mock the [__]
out of people, right, who are correct while she's wrong. And
it creates this really weird disconnect that is hilarious.
That's that's like my favorite part about her. Those are like
the funniest moments. It's the whistleblower moment. That's like
chef's kiss. Okay. Anyway, okay. Hold on. We're looking around.
We're looking around. Uh yeah, I should I should be able to set
a timer for my gen chat. I didn't realize Gen Chat was still
locked, guys. Apparently, Gen Chat's still locked. Who knew?
Not me.
Not me at all. Okay, what are we doing now? We
Hold on. What are we pivoting to next? I think it might be the
Yeah, it might just be Here's the thing. I want to go on to
the BB Net and Yahoo stuff. Okay, I kind of want to go on to
that. But at the same time, now that we just did all of that,
listen, now that we just did all of that, my my programming came
my mind is starting to kick in. I'm like, technically Aerodite
did did interview Teeto today. Should we go cover infinite air
content? Okay, I think so. I think just because I could put that
on the back burner for like a day. I think I want to go do the
Netanyahu stuff. But I'm I'm so tempted in a spiteful way to
go do all the Aeronite stuff again.
H
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I did want to just cover Destiny
like fuming about Hassan really quickly before I get into the
the This is like during the Nekboy stuff. One second. One second.
One second. What is this?
The Why did this time stamp not work?
Uh t equals 3 uh 9632.
I don't know why this time stamp didn't >> A war criminal
by the international he's such a Oh my god. Look at that graying
>> Also, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Before we check it
out, before we check it out, guys, we're going to end on Twitch.
Go over to kick for the rest of the stream. I love you if you're
on Twitch, but we're going to kick for the rest of the stream.
Thank you very much for watching on Twitch. Don't forget to throw
your Twitch Primes on your way out. Okay, Twitch Prime reset
day was today. Lots of people have their Twitch primes reset.
Do heard I just got here? No, I'm good.
Uh, I'm good. I'm good. I'm good. All right.
Where are we going? Where are we going? Oh, yes. Ending the Twitch
stream, guys. We'll see you over on kick. Okay. We'll see you
over on kick. We're ending the Twitch stream. Bye-bye. Boom.
Boom. Boom. Boom. Boom. Boom. Boom. Boom. All right. Here we
are. We're headed on to this. We're continuing with the Destiny
content.
>> Just like a podcast there. You know what I mean? Like
he's literally the prime minister that is a war criminal by the
>> God. He's such a Oh my god. Look at that graying disgusting
beard. What? Did he stop? Look at that gray disgusting beard.
What a
Okay. Um, you are literally a You literally drink [__]
You lit You are literally like more disgusting to everybody on
the planet than Hassan. There's literally not a single person
on the planet who finds you less disgusting than Hassan. I'm
sorry. It's there's just literally nothing there, right?
It's it's so bizarre. Also, pretty sure people like the salt
and pepper beard for Hassan. Let's see. Let's see. >> God,
he's such a [__] Oh my god. Look at that graying
disgusting beard. What? Did he stop dying the rest of it? This
>> 50year-old unmarried disgraceful to his
>> God. Oh no. >> Their [__] family is
his brother. >> Oh no,
bro. Is there a single Is there a single one of those criticisms
that doesn't apply harsh more harshly to Destiny?
Is there a single one?
Is there a single one? No, that applies far more to Destiny.
Disgusting beard. Far more to Destiny. Embarrassing to his loved
ones. Far more to Destiny, bro.
Oh, wait. Hold on. Hold on. >> 50-year-old unmarried disgraceful.
>> I don't believe Destiny's currently >> Billionaire.
Is his brother at least married? Is somebody making kids for
these degenerate losers? >> Is somebody making kids for
these degenerate losers?
>> Oh god.
>> So many children. >> Did any of the wealthy college
women that he did any of them have any kids? God, I hate this.
>> The wealthy college women that he
Okay,
This guy's falling off so hard. It's amazing. Do you remember
when Destiny was the guy who was like, you know, guys, I hate
Hassan. Everyone knows I don't like Hassan, but I'm going to
be fair to Hassan and say like this. Remember when he was that?
And now he's just here like taking all of the things that people
laugh at him for, okay, and trying to flip those onto Hassan.
This is like insane projection. This crazy >> This guy
so much. Imagine going on a show like this and being like a war
criminal. Meanwhile, this dude has a [__] reservoir
built up of nostrila in his in his in his closet that he sits
there and chugs while he's got No, he did it again. He did it
again. There's no way that he just did another come drinking
joke. I literally mocked him for this 30 seconds ago.
Dude, this guy cannot stop thinking about drinking [__]
at all times of the day. He can't help it. He literally can't
help it. It's so weird.
It's so
Like everybody else just says you're sucking somebody off or
you're meat riding, meat watching, meat riding. Okay, you're
glazing.
Every accusation is a confession. Dude, dude, it's every one
of them. He can't go guzzling buckets of dude.
Videos of dead Syrians in the background playing because he loves
Hezbollah. He loves every terrorist as long as they're
against Israel, I guess. >> Ask him. >> Unless they're
against Israel. He loves terrorists unless they're against Israel.
I think he loves them if they're with against Israel, right?
>> Dead Syrians in the background playing because he loves
Hezbollah. He loves every terrorist as long as they're >> against
Israel. I guess
questions unless people want to know. >> Got it.
against Israel, I guess. >> Ask loves every [__]
terrorist as long as they're >> I guess
that I think people wanted to know. >> Okay. Okay. What
did he What did he say? I mean, of course. So, for starving,
>> I don't know if there's anything else here said that
they bring the food in and steals it. >> We're going to
watch a bunch of these interviews, by the way, >> and then
sells it. >> No, that's a lie.
>> Past does not possess the gene. That's why he's angry.
Uh, sure.
We know that. Okay. We know. We know. We know. We know. We know.